WE THANK THE PRODUCERS SO MUCH
AND THANK THE MOTHERS THAT
.
GRIFF: 11 STATES ARE SET TO
START EASING CORONAVIRUS
RESTRICTIONS TOMORROW AS
PROTESTS RAMP UP THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY OVER LOCKDOWN ORDERS.
MANY AMERICANS HITTING THE
STREETS THIS WEEKEND TO PUT
PRESSURES ON THEIR GOVERNORS
DEMANDING TO LET THEM GET BACK
TO WORK, AND SO NOW WE WANT TO
BRING IN THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF
ARKANSAS AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, GOOD MORNING
TO YOU.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS THIS
MORNING ON THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT PEOPLE HAVE HAD
ABOUT ENOUGH BEING TOLD TO STAY
HOME, DON’T GO ANYWHERE, DON’T
DO ANYTHING.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE SAFE.
PEOPLE HAVE APPLIED
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FRIENDS AND THEIR NEIGHBORS BUT
THERE’S ALSO A POINT THAT WE
CANNOT LIVE HUNKERED DOWN
FOREVER.
IT’S NOT LIKE BOMBS ARE DROPPING
ON TOP OF LONDON.
WE’RE AT A TIME WHEN WE’VE GOT
TO GET BACK TO WORK OR THERE’S
NOT GOING TO BE ANYTHING TO GET
OUT OF THE HOUSE TO GO BACK TO.
SO INCREASINGLY GOVERNORS ARE
RAMPING UP.
AND IT’S INTERESTING TO NOTE,
BRIAN KEMP IN GEORGIA IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE.
PEOPLE WERE JUST HAMMERING HIM
FOR STARTING TO OPEN BACK UP.
BUT HIS STATE HAS SEEN THE
LOWEST NUMBER OF COVID-19 CASES
NOW SINCE THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED.
RON DeSANTIS IN FLORIDA WHERE I
AM RIGHT NOW, HE WAS GETTING
HAMMERED.  "HE WASN’T DOING
ENOUGH."
BUT THE TRUTH IS FLORIDA HAS A
BIGGER POPULATION THAN NEW YORK,
MORE SENIOR POPULATION THAN NEW
YORK, AND A SMALL FRACTION OF
THE NUMBER OF CASES.
SO THESE GOVERNORS WHO HAVE
MANAGED BY SAYING, "LET’S NOT
QUICKLY" HAVE ACTUALLY HAD FAR
BETTER RESULTS THAN THE ONES WHO
CLOSED THE DOORS, LOCKED THE KEY
AND STARTED ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR
DOING SUCH THINGS AS GETTING A
HAIRCUT OR BUYING SEEDS TO PLANT
TOMATOES IN THEIR GARDEN.
PETE: YEAH.
I MEAN, 60% OF THE CASES IN NEW
YORK CAME FROM PEOPLE AT HOME AS
WELL.
IS THERE A PERVERSE INCENTIVE IN
SOME CASES FOR POLITICIANS TO
SORT OF MOVE THE GOALPOSTS AND
CONTINUE TO KEEP IT LOCKED DOWN
TO SAY, HEY, WE’RE GOING TO
PREVENT EVERY SINGLE DEATH WE
CAN?
OF COURSE WE WANT TO DO THAT,
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE’S A
POLITICAL INCENTIVE TO DO THAT,
.
>> WELL, THERE MAY BE A
POLITICAL INCENTIVE.
YOU KNOW, THERE’S CERTAINLY A
REVOLTING.
WE DON’T LIVE IN A POLICE STATE.
I’VE BEEN ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I’VE BEEN, AS YOU HAVE, PETE, TO
PLACES THAT ARE AUTHORITARIAN,
TOTALITARIAN GOVERNMENTS.
AND EVERY TIME I’M THERE, I’M
THINKING, I WANT TO GET OUT OF
HERE.
THIS IS NOT AMERICA.
I LIKE FREEDOM.
AND I’VE VISITED SOME POLICE
STATES.
I DON’T WANT TO LIVE IN ONE.
AND I THINK ONE THING WE ARE
BEGINNING TO RECOGNIZE IS PART
OF THE REASON THIS HAS EXTENDED
IS BECAUSE ALL OF THE GOVERNMENT
PEOPLE WHO ARE TELLING US TO
LOCK OUR DOORS AND NOT GO
ANYWHERE, THEY’RE ALL GETTING
THEIR PAYCHECKS, EVERY LAST ONE
OF THEM.
NOT ONE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE IS
FAILING TO GET THEIR PAYCHECK.
SO IF WE REALLY WANT TO SOLVE
THIS, LET’S SAY THIS.
IF YOU’RE A GOVERNMENT PERSON
AND YOU’RE TELLING OTHER PEOPLE
THEY CAN’T GET THEIR PAY, YOU
DON’T GET YOURS.
AND THAT INCLUDES NANCY PELOSI
AND THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
EMILY: GOVERNOR, PART OF WHAT
IMPRESSES ME SO MUCH ABOUT YOU
IS YOUR ABILITY TO ARTICULATE SO
SIMPLY AND CLEARLY SOLUTIONS,
AND THAT’S PARTLY WHAT I LOVED
ABOUT YOUR BOOK, "SIMPLE
GOVERNMENT."
AND SO I WANTED TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE U.S.’S
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA; RIGHT?
BECAUSE WE’RE SPARRING WITH
CHINA RIGHT NOW OVER MANY THINGS
AND WE HAVE FOR SO LONG.
AND RIGHT NOW WE’RE SPARRING
WITH THEM OVER THE PRO-HU
LANGUAGE AND U.N. SECURITY
COUNCIL CEASEFIRE RESOLUTION
LANGUAGE, AND BEIJING WANTED TO
MENTION HU’S ROLE -- WE HAVE
DEMANDED FOR CRITICAL LANGUAGE.
WHAT IS YOUR SOLUTION THAT YOU
RECOMMEND, WHAT ARE YOUR
CHINA’S GRIP?
>> WELL, GREAT QUESTION, WHO’S
CHINA’S GRIP.
THIS STARTED WHEN A LOT OF
AMERICAN MULTINATIONAL,
GLOBALIST COUNTRIES DECIDED THEY
COULD MAKE A REAL QUICK BUCK BY
SHIPPING ALL THE MANUFACTURING
THAT WE USED TO DO HERE TO CHINA
WHERE CHEAP LABOR WOULD DO IT
WITHOUT ANY REGARD WHATSOEVER
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT OR FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES.
SO WE DID THAT, AND WE HAD CHEAP
STUFF.
BUT NOW WE’RE SEEING THE CHEAP
STUFF UNDER THE IRON HAND OF
COMMUNISM ISN’T CHEAP AT ALL.
IT’S LIKE "PAY ME NOW, PAY ME
LATER."
WELL, WE’RE PAYING.
BOY, ARE WE EVER PAYING FOR ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT WE SOLD OUT
TO CHINA.
AND, FRANKLY, THE WAY THAT THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION, WHO,
HAS KOWTOWED TO CHINA IS
DISCUSSING AND REVOLTING AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS EXACTLY RIGHT
TO DO WHAT HE’S DONE.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
I’VE GOT MORE CONFIDENCE IN THE
ROCK BAND WHO THAN I HAVE IN THE
.
GRIFF: GOOD LINE.
GOVERNOR, GIVING YOU A CHANCE TO
SHARE YOUR MOTHER’S DAY THOUGHTS
>> WELL, HAPPY MOTHER’S DAY TO
ALL THE MOMS.
MY OWN MOTHER HAS BEEN DECEASED
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
I’VE GOT A PHOTO OF HER BUT NOT
ONE WITH ME BECAUSE SHE REFUSED
TO BE SEEN WITH ME IN PUBLIC
FROM THE TIME I WAS A TOT.
I HAVE A WONDERFUL WIFE TO HER
THREE CHILDREN AND A WONDERFUL
GRANDMOTHER TO HER SIX
GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE’S RECOVERING FROM A BRONCO
ANKLE, STEPPED ON A GRANDCHILD’S
TOY; SO HER MOTHER’S DAY IS A
LOT MORE PAINFUL THAN IT OUGHT
TO BE.
FACING SURGERY TOMORROW.
PETE: WE HOPE SHE RECOVERS